si vous regardez alors vous savez
maintenant qu'un gros problème se dirige
vers nous une réunion d'urgence est
prévue à l'endroit habituel au plus vite
avec une ce faire
j'ai fait une découverte effrayante
j'ai besoin de vous pour contacter la
nasa immédiatement un bug la nasa on
peut dire qu'on est un petit peu en
froid alors ça va changer
quand vous leur direz que la lune est
sorti de son orbite
aucune raison de paniquer je suis
partout
justin a caché tout ça il est trop tard
pour l'arrêter
aviez tout compris avant la naissance
c'est vous la source anonyme oui
nous une entité intelligente
organise une mission pour attaquer cette
chance c'est de ton aide dont j'ai
besoin
je veux qu'il soit correct et
si la lune est vraiment ce que tu penses
tu viens avec nous
m
et se décoller
il a bien dit on de gravité
[Musique]
les mains
c'est fou
mon but
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le plan b la lune sauver la
terre
c'est pas moi
attention
tu vas voir christophe
[Musique]
jamais
il est en mode avion
[Musique]